there are some penguins found further
north like the African penguin which is
found in South Africa it was a South
African penguin and they had apartheid
black and white living together yeah why
didn't they look to the penguin Mandela
really missed an opportunity yeah
I'll tell you my Mandela story very
quickly so there was there was a there
was a uh a promoter and he had a picture
of uh him and Nelson Mandela on his desk
and I was like geez and I was in South
Africa's geez that was a good picture of
you and Mandela and he goes it used to
be a much better photo before right he
pulled it out of his frame and he built
it bent it back on the other side of
Mandela was Bill Cosby
from when he promoted Bill Cosby there
and Mandela asked to meet Cosby and the
guy still wanted to keep the photo so he
just bent it over the side yeah